this hit
goes out to you Mr Wick
42 regular wasn't it yeah
And So It Begins Hello friends I am
sitting next to you great friends the
director and star of John Wick chapter
four Chad stachelski and Keanu Reeves it
is truly an honor to be like sharing the
same oxygen as you guys like I I really
mean that and growing up I feel like
people around me I would always hear
them use this phrase like women love bad
guys to which I would always respond bad
guys like John Wick like John Wick to me
has always been this more than meets the
eye Action Hero you know he's in touch
with his emotions he has this Chuck
Norris meme ability to him he has this
unrelentless motivation and Temperance
like he knows when to strike which is
like something I wish I could embody
when I have a crush on someone anyway so
I that is why I love John Wick and I'm
so excited to talk to you guys about
chapter four from the looks of the
trailer it looks just Insanity like
John's kicking the global Hornet's Nest
he's going after the high table not
running from them anymore and it just
bigger and better than ever and that's
such an accomplishment and with any
accomplishment for me I always feel like
the incremental steps along the way are
the most delicious part like when I go
camping I'm like I can't wait to buy
s'mores supplies so since it's been four
years Keanu since we've seen the last
week I wanted to know what got you so
excited about jumping into WIC this time
around is it like getting fitted for
pristine Kevlar suits is it learning
Japanese what are you like um I can't
wait
uh the story we had to tell
and the chance to play the character and
and tell the story like I felt like
there was a reason for chapter four
you know we had a reason and I was just
looking forward to tell the story and
play the role was there one part of the
story particular that you were like oh I
can't wait to like train for this or can
we
can we
um yeah there's always tons of stuff
Chad was saying we're bringing the cars
back so I was like do I get to drive a
car and he's like yes and I'm like okay
cool and then he's like start training
it's tomorrow at nine and I'm like cool
and um
and so yeah there was that nunchucks and
so there was a lot of skills to learn
and um but really the story and the cast
of characters that came out of
developing the story and and then
turning into the story we were telling
uh was really exciting and this you guys
are so good at story it's not just
action there is always this like
compelling story that you're on the edge
of your seat for because of Mr stahlski
piano and the actors and the actors and
everyone
um I read that you said that this was
like one of the hardest and most
difficult films that you've done how do
you feel like chapter four no not one
the the hardest how do you feel like
this pushed you beyond the limits that
you thought you were capable of I think
it's just the um the opportunities that
I had in the film to to try and do some
action and and that for me is you know
bringing the audience along you know
dramatically to be able to see the
struggles that John's having and trying
to overcome you know fighting for his
life
uh and so you know it it it's not only
the intensity of the action but also the
timeline of it you know just with the
months of training and then the filming
yeah I know you put a lot into it yeah
like nine but that's its gift yeah you
know but that's also what's so exciting
about it Chad I imagine for you first
and foremost seeing you go from being
piano stun guy like in The Matrix to
being a full-fledged director has been
so inspiring to watch and I just want to
thank you and commend you for letting
scenes breathe and shooting action in
such a beautiful and intentional way uh
Rick Rubin says this about wrestling but
he says it's like everyone just trying
to put on the best show ever and that's
why it feels like you're watching ballet
instead of watching a fight when you
watch a John Wick movie there's 14
Action sequences in chapter four four
more than any other four times more than
any other John Wick film I wish I could
ask you about all of them but let's
start with The Arc the scene that
I saw in the trailer it looks so dope so
aggressive can you break down that scene
for us and tell us the challenges that
it posed sure I think
um I guess the counter's point how we
put them all together is like okay
what's the story how do you you don't I
don't think we've ever really thought
how do we go bigger or better it's just
how do you get more story out of it and
how do you expand
um so we did something like that it's
not just about cars but what were we
trying to do with the cars where are we
trying to go where are we trying to get
to and what are you learning about John
in the in the sequence so for arcatri
Triumph we kind of had this idea of like
look we do a lot of the martial art
fights and we do a lot of the driving
we're like oh let's just put them
together and that's kind of how that one
went
um enable to control your environment
able to do you know I think what we have
30 cars
30 stunt drivers and another 30 I think
we put in a few digital background cars
but then with our our our fight team we
put that in so Keanu is actually driving
against other drivers against traffic as
we're going around in a big circle oh my
God kind of drift and weave in between
cars and um
Kiana is so good with the with the
Tactical firearm work that he's actually
shooting reloading I don't do a
reloading right on that one we're
shooting and doing all the stuff as
we're going as he's drifting a car which
I think is pretty cool and then when he
gets out of the car he's having his
fight tactical sequence in and amongst
live traffic because there's other games
coming out because there's all kinds of
there's an open contract on John Wick
we've done the massive Gauntlet
probably the most logistical tricky one
yeah you don't want to hit job for the
bus yeah but a lot of people are getting
hit by cars we have a lot in the air
a lot of stunt guys getting hit by cars
so insane I'm throwing people into cars
it's amazing I was reading that you guys
were training for this or you know
because you couldn't shut all the lanes
down in an abandoned airport in Berlin
outside of Berlin wow that's where we
started these ideas shot and these
fights are so good and the imagination
isn't restrained like the physical world
is so I've always wanted to ask you did
that idea
start from a much grander starting point
um or was that it uh again there's so
many different inputs I guess you start
with the cast member right and you see
what the limitations are and then when
you recount whatever they're hard to
reach limitations so if you have a guy
that puts that much time into driving in
a martial arts and a shooting
you can expand everything and then we
get some of the best teams out there and
we kind of all collect that we get
together
and we bring in ideas and about how does
it again it's always like we try to
avoid a lot of shoe leather I mean we
just don't go a to b instead of just
doing a long
16 block car chase we go let's just
drive around in a circle uh I know that
sounds silly but you'll have more time
to do things and you'll have more things
to do so every event is a is a gag to a
gag to a gag to a gag to a gag so it
seems a lot more exciting a lot more
busy than just you know driving straight
in the steering but that can be really
good too yeah it can at the right time
we just want to try something different
that other shows hadn't tried so uh it's
all base two just like the fight scenes
if you keep your cast and it's the dance
mentality right you're seeing Gene Kelly
and if Gene Kelly is doing all the
dancing you can get more incredible
shots so if I have Keanu and keanu's
doing the driving and the fighting and
the shooting I can stay in shots that a
lot of other shows can't get that's kind
of our little secret the Gene Kelly of
fighting I mean he talked about the time
you put in Keanu and it's so true like
you were brushing up on your driving
skills for nine months like no I wasn't
brushing up on my skills for nine months
but uh little brushing but some new
skills sounds great no no I mean I got
to throw some 180s John Wick training is
extraordinary I get to work with such
extraordinary people and and get you
know taught you know I'm getting
one-on-one I'm getting the tools whether
it's a car set up right you know the
space to do things
um who are very patient with me and uh
so I'm really giving you know
you know I'm basically there come on
reefs and you know for me as he speaks
about
you know what he can do with what I can
do
what I can do is trying to help realize
what Chad can do right and so I have a
limit and Chad doesn't assume
division so I'm like the I'm which is
tough because I'm like the limiter right
so well I to me you and to most people
watching these you are boundless and I I
wanted to ask you about fear because
fear can be so comedically subjective
like before I go live on TV I experience
fear I get really scared and yet I'll go
gorilla trekking without a Flinch and
it's so funny to me do you experience
fear when you're pulling off these crazy
fight sequences or is this just like a
gorilla track for you
I think it's something in between
you know I think I think going through
the training there's a hope you know
like there's a goal I hope I can do that
I hope I can do this
um and then you go through the training
where you hope that it can become second
nature
and so that part is kind of gorilla
trekking in a way where you have
um well I can't speak to gorilla
checking so I feel pressure I feel
nervous I feel but also concentrated and
I think that's where you know you don't
want fear to you or hold you
back but you also like the excitement
and fear of the intensity for the goal
but then there's also some times where
you're like I got it
um
I love that but but not very often
because then also you're you know during
the middle of a fight you also have to
go unconscious too yeah you know
but you have to be present unconsciously
you also have this ability to say so
much without using words Keanu like in
every role you've ever done do you have
an inner monologue or Mantra that you
hold on to for John when you're fighting
in these sequences yeah don't die
but I mean I think I think it's like
what does the character want and the
character is trying to survive and he's
fighting for his freedom and so that is
the core thing that's in it but he's
also
he also comes from the dark
there's some dark thoughts in there too
yeah
especially if you're trying to kill me
or if I'm taking revenge or and I think
that's part of the John Wick story
because he's trying to
integrate as a person the John and the
John Wick the man and the Assassin
speaking of mantras there's a lot of new
themes in this movie that I'm really
excited about that we're gonna get to
experience through some new characters
like I feel like we're gonna get some
Brotherhood some hope some
father-daughter relationships which I
love because mine is very sacred to me
uh through characters played by the Epic
and legendary Donnie Yen and hiroyuki
Sonata what can you tell us about those
two characters their history with John
and then Kiana would love to hear what
it was like reuniting what's NADA after
doing 47 Ronin with him ah thank you
yeah
um no we wanted to try
again to count as earlier point we
usually sit around after we finish like
we finish three
we're like okay we're done then we go on
tour and we're like hanging out we lost
some ideas we start writing a napkin so
you're like okay what do you think oh
and it literally came about that simple
of like okay well is this worth doing
another one we don't have a story it's
not really worth it we had a story but a
lot of it came through like Brotherhood
and Hope just kind of what you said and
we're like oh we have some ideas we want
friendship we want to see causality
about John's choices and one of the
easiest ways to see causality is through
relationships so we wanted to form some
really solid relationships with people
that you hadn't quite met yet in the
John Wick world and you know instantly
we go to you know best friends okay
what's that uh camaraderie what would it
be like to be someone to be John's best
friend and what were the penalties you'd
pay for being his friend and that's kind
of how we put uh Donnie Yen's character
and hiroyuki sonata's character uh all
three of them good friends just the
other two on different sides of
unfortunately the scale that's kind of
balancing out what what John's behind
table Yeah the high table one's on or
being forced be on the high table side
the other one's choosing to I guess
rebel against the high table and the
consequences and the actions they do to
both support and befriend John and we
thought that was really interesting and
again
I don't know I guess we just really like
the father-daughter aspect of saying
something yeah um and that's how Donnie
Yen's character has a daughter that we
briefly meet and then hiroyuki sonata's
character's daughter uh played by Rina
samayama she's actually a big part of
the film at least in the First Act and
we used both his leverage points as both
as kind of I don't know reflections of
who the men are yeah they're deciano's
Point Duality if we're there what a dope
addition to her music is so good we
didn't know that we're looking at cast
and I was on the internet looking and I
saw on YouTube on the side it was Rina
in this orange wig for previous I didn't
know anything about her I just thought
that was a cool wig because we're
looking for an interesting look for
for the character Akira and then I
clicked on it and we went down the
rabbit hole and we're like oh my God
like she's a pop star that's cool she
can dance she must be good at fights it
was like that and we got her people on
the phone I managed to talk to her I'm
like hi this is going to sound really
weird
I'm Chad director John Wicks have your
student John Wick and she went crazy on
the phone she's like I love the joke I'm
like would you like to be in one wow and
that's kind of how it just we flew to
Berlin got to meet Keanu we all talked
and see if she's up for it when the
training began yeah the train is insane
wasn't a cool story yeah no she came out
she was so full of energy just talk
about you can see why she's been
successful in that realm she showed up
ready to go from London just came to
Berlin where we were training and I
don't think missed a day was just in it
and it was a different world for her wow
and she was she was great can't wait to
see that yeah yeah she's great what was
it like reuniting with Sonata
uh really uh special uh we had a we've
done a film together called 47 Ronin and
uh it was a great experience and
um so to get to act with him again was
something very special he's a very
profound cat
and uh so to have that
have that passed with him
to be able to have that connection and
then to bring that to these characters
in John Wick
um I think helped with the
seen unknown
but felt kind of thing and he's such a
gentleman and consonant artist and very
authentic he really really helped us out
with the underlying themes yeah we have
a pretty heavy Japanese underlying theme
yeah yeah wow we had some luck
yeah it's been a long time since you and
I
it was been a long time since you and I
have been good men a long time no we
stopped being good men a long time ago
yeah oh what a line I love that it's
and to have like their talents in these
sword fight or Donnie Yen was holding
swords and I love swords and Chad I was
I was in Malibu the other day watching a
surfer um reading waves and he was just
like waiting for the perfect wave and I
was like man I wish I knew how to read
waves and sometimes I feel like that
watching fighting sequences I'm like oh
man if I if I just knew more I could
appreciate it that much better in the
same way a cinematographer picks a
certain lens for a scene how do you
choose like which fighting style is
correct for a scene and are we seeing
fusions that maybe the average person
like wouldn't wouldn't pick up on in
this movie yes to both I think
um how you choose well
um
we've we've been doing choreography for
a very long time and all the guys on our
team are all the people on our team men
and women are from many different styles
I know you just get it it's like what
clothes do you wear honey do you dress
up for the restaurant the club what do
you want to say with it you look at the
cast members you look at their body type
look what they can do and sometimes you
just kind of meet in the middle
um
it's like the ever tightening circle of
perfection you start with these ideas
and sometimes they don't work but
sometimes they go we originally started
with literally three gun not even three
gun tactical shooting and Judo I'm like
that's just we want to grab people
because we thought John Wick was a
grabber
and he was really good with guns so I
mean guns have worked the same way for
quite some time for farms in general of
just doing reloads and all that stuff
it's just on most shows up until right
around uh the military show started not
too long ago you didn't see reloads you
didn't see people clear Chambers the
guns always worked they didn't Jam we
just went well it's just do what's real
and we'll show our guys doing the
reloads and doing all the stuff and we
put that together with Close Quarter
Aikido aiki Jitsu Judo all the
grappling arts and then we just kind of
added in a few other things and it's
like you know we call it the Bloodsport
mentality you have the Thai boxer fight
the Judo guy and the problems that that
could cause
that's what's interesting right it's
like two people speak different
languages trying to communicate if you
have both of us speaking English now we
communicate as would be expected the
other way to do it is very subversive
how do you communicate with me if I
don't speak a word of English and if
I've never met you before if I don't
know anything about our social habits it
it would be interesting to just and
that's what we do with martial arts we
figure what are the interesting
combinations and synthesize and
synthesize and commits yep right so you
have Donnie who's amazing at modern day
fighting traditional film and Kung Fu
then you give them a sword cane you make
them blind and you give them a gun yeah
there's going to be some sympathizing
there you know and we go sometimes we're
not always sure what we're going to get
that's why we're crazy about rehearsal
time and we do all these chunks and
ideas and we sit together and as we
watch it's like forming a dance
and you see how they react together God
what an incredible answer to that thank
you both um so many questions you
mentioned rehearsal uh the Marquee
people are really excited about the
marquee uh and played by Bill Skarsgard
main adversary I'd love to know what he
what challenges he present to John that
John hasn't faced before and his suits
are so killer shout out to Paco Delgado
I think right the costume designer on
this like they're so good and it made me
wonder do you train with suits on like
when you guys are learning choreography
because I won't even show up to
Thanksgiving and jeans yeah I'll I'll
start I trained with a suit on in in the
first one and then I'll do it at the end
and then basically got back to where I
just do the jacket now because the
costume designer knows how to make the
pants
um
some Bill rehearsed with the belt the
Taco Bell holsters yeah let's see Jack
you kind of have to yeah at some point
but yeah build Skarsgard it's amazing
and Paco's amazing and uh yeah Bill's
playing a villain
but
he doesn't think he's the villain no
Bill's a new sheriff in town yeah come
and make a statement yeah
and there's a lot of power yeah a lot of
power and he's playing by the rules he's
doing everything he can
and clean up the mess that John has made
over the last three movies he's got
something to prove and he has ambition a
lot of Ambitions let's talk about this
mess because you were also mentioning
reloading and that's the best part of
John Wick and and piano I'm sure you
know this but the science Community
recently named a molecule after you that
can kill microbes so efficiently because
you were just so deadly my friend in
every role you do what is the body count
on John Wick 4 and and how long is the
movie because I know it's the longest
set of all the previous ones um to be
really honest with you
um I don't I my editorial team has gone
through the final Final Cut and they
they actually know the calculator thing
I ask not to be informed
um I don't know I kind of wanted to be a
surprise when I figured out I don't know
the exact I have a pretty good idea a
rough but I don't know the exact number
um run time uh without credits with just
movie end to end I think is two hours
and 37 and 54. it's almost 200 or 200 2
hours 38 minutes and then there's like
10 minutes of credits because we shot in
like five countries nice and the body
count Kiana I have no idea I think
um yeah I never know those things coming
out of the film when I first got to
speak to you it was virtually for Bill
and Ted the last bill in Ted
and uh you said something to me that
I was replayed in my head in your voice
and you said we're all just humans on a
rock in space and he gave me like this
virtual group hug which was so cool
because I think it was like right in the
height of the pandemic but it made me
want to ask you do would you ever like
to see John fall in love again in these
movies
yeah that's a you know
um
yeah there's a part that wants to on for
me personally that wants to honor his
grief and
uh but then if I thought of what Helen
would want I think she'd want John to
fall in love again well I love the
combination of Chad stahowski and Keanu
Reeves
um you guys both are you you've worked
together for so long you have this
consistency that's so rare in franchises
like this Chad I know you used to teach
kundo at inasanto martial arts academy
and the principals
the principles of that uh fighting style
are Simplicity directness and freedom
and so I wanted to know do you guys have
core principles between the both of you
that you adhere to when working together
probably unspoken but yeah let's see if
we do yeah they're not formalized
yeah I think John Wick one was made just
for a love of action movies the old 70s
kind of action movies like it wasn't
really a plan to do like we don't mind
cutting we don't mind doing shorter
takes or anything like that it's just
We Do It Feels Right it feels
it feels that we both like movies that
breathe like I like walk having John
Wick walk into a building I like seeing
that I like the aftermath of what
happens after the quick fight scene you
know so I think we both have that
similar taste for pacing and for shots
and I guess a common taste for Cinema I
was just gonna say we both like scenario
right we both like Cinema
John Wicks are made the color of the
look the composition we both like
sitting in the theater we like that
magic always love going to the theater
so I think we both kind of went well
we're gonna make an action movie let's
make it for the theater that's kind of
what we've always adhered to
and it's uh I don't know the
unspokenness I guess you say there's
always a subtext or an undertone and I
think that's why people like the
character because we don't just spill it
all out you have to actually watch it
and you can make your own assumptions
which I think is cool yeah I think it's
a cinema common taste hopes Ambitions
dreams storytelling love of movies
John Wicks are just because we like
making them and I think they're all
attributes like there's a lot of apology
and Leone and
Cantina and all the old westerns and Lee
Marvin Steve McQueen
it's all in there